le régime des rentes du québec comporte
plusieurs mesures favorables aux femmes
selon une étude de la chaire de
recherche en fiscalité et en finances
publiques de l'université de sherbrooke
trois variables ont été prises en compte
l'espérance de vie le salaire gagné la
présence d'enfants pour comprendre tout
cela antoine jeunes et grégoire qui est
chercheur associé à la chaire bonsoir
alors pourquoi vous avez fait cette
étude quel est l'intérêt de l'étude à la
base il ya une tendance généralisée
essayer de se mettre à considérer
comment nos politiques publiques ont des
effets qui sont pas les mêmes pour les
hommes et les femmes même si la loi ou
le règlement qui définit politique et
est écrit de façon neutre
les hommes et femmes n'ont pas les mêmes
situations de vie et puis ça a des
impacts quand on combine ça avec les
politiques donc c'est quelque chose
qu'on compte en généraliser à l'achat on
avait déjà étudié comment les mesures
fiscales à fait différent différemment
les hommes et les femmes
on avait déjà étudié le rrq par exemple
quand on le bonifier donc on s'est dit
qu'on allait combiner les deux essayer
de voir comment la rrq plus mal iris qui
sommes en apparence et un régime qui
serait paraît il pareil pour les hommes
et les femmes
en réalité à cause de la situation
différente des deux il ya des effets qui
sont dans ce cas elle est favorable aux
femmes on part de la prime issus le dit
que les femmes sont désavantagées pour
toutes sortes de raisons généralement on
a cette impression là mais effectivement
les femmes ont en général des revenus
qui sont plus faire des salaires sont
plus faibles plus de difficultés à
accéder aux postes de haute direction et
cetera donc c'est probablement une bonne
chose à se conclure qu'on est entre
autres du rrq des politiques qui
potentiellement compense en partie pour
ces faits le qui nuisent à la
préparation à la retraite
oui donc c'est ça autrement dit aux
potes d'égalité exact il ya une
compensation c'est ça c'est ça qu'on
voit alors prenons un cas type là un
homme une femme des enfants
expliquez-nous un cas type pour faire
votre étude
l'étude qu'on a fait c'est à l'évasion
des simulations donc une simulation top
si vous voulez ça serait celle d'un
homme qui toute sa carrière durant gang
le salaire maximal admissible au rrq ça
c'est environ 57 mille dollars cette
année et on le compare avec une femme
qui gagne environ 75% de ce plafond le
ce qui est grosso modo l'écart qu'on
retrouve dans les revenus en femme en
plus de ça la faim dans un scénario saab
semble du marché du travail deux fois
pendant 2
la naissance de ses enfants ce qui est
typiquement plus beaucoup plus souvent
le cas pour les femmes que pour les
hommes et à ce moment il n'y a pas de
cotisations à la rrq exactement donc le
rrq ou ce qu'on cotise est inclus dans
un calcul qui nous donne ce qu'on reçoit
à la retraite au rrq les années pour
lesquelles on reçoit des prestations
familiales elle ne compte pas dans le
calcul donc typiquement sur sap sont du
marché du travail
le compteur du rrq continue de tourner
mais on cotise pas donc ça tirait nos
prestations vers le bas mais dans ce
colosse ces années là elles sont exclues
donc ça ça donne un avantage aux femmes
majoritairement aux femmes à travers le
régime
un autre gros élément c'est que
contrairement si on s'achetait ne rentre
dans le secteur privé
le rrq offre le même montant de rente à
salaire égal à tout le monde mais les
hommes et les femmes n'ont pas la même
espérance de vie ce qui fait qu'en
moyenne les femmes vont toucher du rrq
trois ans de plus si on suit à
l'espérance de vie en général vont
toucher la même rampe 3 ans de plus donc
ça aussi c'est un avantage qui va du
côté des femmes
et puis finalement il ya dans les
cotisations au rrq une exemption de base
de 3500 $ donc sur les premiers 3500
draps qu'on gagne on n'a pas à payer de
cotisations au rrq
ouais donc ça fait que le taux de
cotisation plus notre revenu est faible
plus le taux de cotisation qu'on paie et
réduit donc une petite redistribution de
lorsque la 10ème à revenus plus élevés
dans les femmes qui ont des revenus
généralement plus faible et donc dans
votre cas type 100% du salaire
admissible pour l'homme 75% pour la
femme deux enfants retrait du marché du
travail à deux reprises
les deux sont nés en 1960 retraite à 60
ans demande le régime à 65
vraiment c'est le cas type et voici donc
le résultat autrement dit de ce que vous
avez découvert c'est que les prestations
reçues par les femmes représentent 3,4
fois les cotisations qu'elles ont versé
alors que les hommes ça représente 2,8
fois les cotisations qu'ils ont versé
exactement dans tous les cas on retire
plus que ce qu'on a mis dans le régime
et c'est normal parce que cet argent
aurait confié la caisse de dépôt donc on
espère effectivement clients rendement
mais à cause de ces différences là qui
font que les danses que la femme à des
cotisations moindre mais saft potins
directement sa prestation que dans le
cas de l'homme
le rendement de chaque dent
ans de cotisation de la femme dans ce
cas là est plus élevé que celui de
l'homme notre avis après 18%
donc on s'en va c'est relatif là c'est
relatif est relatif aux cotisations les
femmes vont moins cotiser mais
relativement à leurs cotisations elles
ont des prestations plus importante dans
notre exemple la femme quand même une
prestation qui est plus faible que celle
de l'homme dans ce cas là par contre les
moins fait plus faible que le serai
l'assemblée différence de salaire à
cause de son espérance de vie à cause
d'exclusion des années parentalité et à
cause que ces cotisations sont un petit
peu plus bas
est-ce que c'est des résultats étonnants
c'est pas des résultats étonnants dans
la mesure où clairement la mesure de la
parentalité par exemple ça a été mis
leurs courses donc surtout quand on a
créé le régime des rentes
c'était évident à ce moment là que les
absences de marché du travail à cause de
la parentalité c'était surtout une
réalité féminin c'est un peu différent
aujourd'hui et ça reste majoritairement
les femmes qui s'absente du marché du
travail
donc même si c'est pas écrit ceci est
une mesure pour les femmes en pratique
tout le monde se doutait que c'en était
une
le fait d'avoir les mêmes prestations
peu importe l'espérance de vie
ça fait très longtemps aussi qu'on sait
que les femmes ont plus d'expérience de
vie donc essentiellement on ne design et
le rrq avec une certaine désir dame est
d'améliorer la condition des femmes et
on voit que ça fonctionne
ouais vous en faites la preuve
aujourd'hui donc si ça vous intéresse
vous retrouvez cette étude sur le site
de la chaire de fiscalité et de finances
publiques antoine je n'ai y voir merci
beaucoup
si vous pensez bien